sobre la reacción china pues la verdad
es que esa es la gran pregunta que hay
ahora por qué
y hemos tenido las litúrgicas protestas
la indignación y como novedad esta vez
hemos tenido una amenaza de algún acto
militar que no se ha concretado la
cuestión es que acto militar va a ser
podemos descartar los más extremos los
analistas hablan por ejemplo de que
algún caza chino hubiera podido
acompañará al avión de pelo si vemos que
no ha sido así que le hubieran podido
obligar a aterrizar en suelo continental
tampoco ha sido así entonces bueno algo
va a tener que hacer china porque si no
va a quedar muy mal no sólo con el mundo
sino todavía más grave para el gobierno
con la audiencia interna mal hace 50
años hablaba de un tigre de papel china
no se puede convertir en eso entonces no
lo sé hoy ha hablado con un experto que
me decía que a lo mejor esas rutinarias
maniobras militares que hace en el
estrecho de taiwán y que hasta ahora
respetaba
digamos lo que es la frontera la
frontera marítima pues que ahora a lo
mejor podría
y traspasarla no son especulaciones pero
desde luego algo va a tener que hacer
hoy por ejemplo ya china anunciaba que
va a prohibir las importaciones y de un
centenar de empresas alimentarias
taiwanesas pero eso no es suficiente eso
no es suficiente para salvar cara así
que cruzaremos los dedos esperemos que
bueno sea una acción militar que sea
suficientemente firme para expresar toda
su indignación pero que sea controlada y
que no lleve esta tensión a extremos
insoportables a china le
diría que le sorprende o la indigna
pues este tipo de acciones que eeuu
minimiza como si fueran fruslerías es
decir
eeuu acá de enviar al mandatario de más
alto rango a taiwán en varias décadas
además está acercando a toda una serie
de barcos y de aviones militares al
estrecho de
de taiwán es decir frente a las narices
de china y lo que decía la casa blanca
ayer es que esto no tiene ningún tipo de
importancia y que si hay algún tipo de
problema que será culpa de pekín claro
eso para pekín se ha esforzado en
explicarle 40.000 veces cuál es la
relevancia que tiene taiwán y la
soberanía pues es bastante comprensible
las relaciones de eeuu y de china van
por mal camino sí y desde luego no
podrán ser buenas si eeuu sigue metiendo
el dedo en el ojo a china en el tema de
taiwán que es sagrado